[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 15
septembre vous regardez le 78 le journal
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition on commence tout de
suite avec les
titres la Société du Grand Paris fait sa
rentrée l'établissement public chargé de
concevoir et construire le réseau de
transport Grand Paris Express a présenté
ce matin l'état d' des différents
chantiers des futures lignes de métro et
améliorer l'emploi et le recrutement
local c'est la volonté de
l'agglomération elle lance ainsi une
grande enquête et des rencontres avec
les entrepreneurs du territoire et enfin
qu'allez-vous faire les journées pour
les journées européenne du patrimoine le
thème cette année patrimoine et
citoyenneté en Île-de-France 1500 lieux
ouvrent leur porte petit tour d'horizon
de ce qu'il y a à voir dans les ivlines
et première et peut-être dernière
journée de mobilisation contre la loi à
travail si elle a été promulguée le 9
août elle suscite toujours de nombreux
mécontentements du côté des syndicats
des salariés et des étudiants à 50 ans
en Yveline l'UNEF le syndicat étudiant a
rejoint la manifestation au départ de la
place de la Bastille à Paris jusqu'à
République je vous propose d'écouter
Naim Chili était au micro de Patrick
Jacques de dixmus c'est le président de
l'Unef des ivlines aujourd'hui on part
en direction de Paris pour rejoindre la
manifestation contre la loi de travail
en effet même si la loi travail est
passée reste toujours aussi inacceptable
et toujours aussi exérable pour notre
avenir et du coup on va manifester
aujourd'hui au côté desin et des
salariés cette loi dans son ensemble
elle est inacceptable elle fait que
augmenter la précarité au travail du
coup on continue à se mobiliser pour le
retrait de la loi de travail dans son
entièreté mais on demande aussi
l'ouverture de discussion parce que des
propositions on en a des propositions
pour améliorer la réussite des jeunes
pour diminuer le chômage et cet et
cetera on en a et c'est pour ça qu'on
demand le retrait de la loi de travail
et l'ouverture de discussion pour de
vraies mesures dans le sens du progrès
social et à Paris entre 12500 et 13500
personnes ont manifesté selon les
chiffres de la préfecture de police
tandis que la CGT en a recensé à 40000
des échaux fourourés ont éclaté à
plusieurs reprises entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre et
dans le reste de l'actualité c'était
l'heure de la rentrée aujourd'hui pour
la Société du Grand Paris
l'établissement public a présenté ce
matin l'état d'avancement des différents
chantiers des futures lignes de métro
dont celle de la ligne 18 qui reliera
Orli à versaill en passant par cquentin
en Yveline alors après la phase de
concertation place au début des travaux
Nicolas kirilovic vous en dit
plus c'est une étape de plus pour le
métro du Grand Paris Express les
premiers travaux ont commencé sur
plusieurs tronçons franciliens c'est le
cas notamment pour les futur ligne 15 et
16 pour la ligne 18 en revanche qui
desservira 50 ans en Eveline les études
techniques sont encore en cours à ce
stade là il y a pas de retard puisquon
en était vraiment aux études
préliminaires maintenant le maître
d'œuvre a été désigné et donc il va
travailler sur les études d'avant-prjet
et c'est à ce niveau des études
d'avant-prjet qu'on fixe définitivement
le tracé de la ligne et la position des
gares à terme la ligne 18 du Grand Paris
Express relira à l'aéroport d'orli à
Versailles coût du projet estimé un peu
moins de 3 milliards d'euros pour une
mise en service total en 2030 d'ici là
plusieurs projets pensés par des
étudiants franciliens verront le jour
l'un d'entre eux doit favoriser les
échanges entre riverins commerçants et
entreprises avec comme espace d'accueil
des containers
ça sera vraiment c'est l'impact visuel
qu'on veut d'abord avoir donc avec le
containur ça vraiment la forme de la
tôle quoi avec une terrasse qu'on a pas
forcément l'habitude de voir sur un
container et l'intérieur par contre sera
vraiment aménagé pour par exemple pour
la restauration avec vraiment les
réfrigérateurs le plan de travail donc
l'intérieur sera vraiment nouveau pour
le consommateur utilisateurs et
consommateurs devront en tout cas se
montrer patients les premières rames de
métro dans les Yvelines n'arriveront pas
avant 14 ans éducation à présent le
premier Forum départemental de
l'apprentissage s'est tenu aujourd'hui à
la mairie de versaill plus de 500 offres
de contrats de professionnalisation ont
été présenté aux étudiants au programme
également des conférences et des
entretiens individuel avec des
professionnels Michel elmidoro était sur
place mettre en lien les étudiants avec
les centres de formation et les
entreprises c'était l'objectif de la
première édition du Forum départemental
de l'apprentissage un événement oranis
ce jeudi à la mairie de versaill selon
les organisateurs 500 offres de contrat
de professionnalisation ét présenté aux
étudiants on a des retour positif de de
certains jeunes qui nous disent bah
voilà que qui bah qui ne connaissaient
pas ce ce centre de formation ou cette
entreprise donc ça amène des solutions à
un public qui des fois est en demande et
aussi perdu parce qu'ils sont jeunes et
on a tendance à l'oublier pour ce
rendez-vous 30 organismes de formation
en apprentissage était présent pour
orienter plus de 500 jeunes ça
permet de répondre au besoins des jeunes
de présenter notre école notre formation
après mes collègues récupèrent les
contacts et on les suit on appelle les
jeunes et on leur propose un contrat
d'apprentissage ou bien on leur propose
la rentrée pour cette année ou pour
l'année prochaine c'est une très très
bonne idée surtout à Versailles un
endroit plutôt facile à trouver avec des
intervenants très intéressants c'est
productif on ressort avec toutes les
réponses aux questions qu'on aurait pu
avoir il nous parl ils ent le dialogue
directement nous cherch il essayent de
chercher ce qu'on cherche nous découvrir
un petit peu et nous montrer un petit
peu comment comment marche entreprise et
voir si ça nous intéresse une deuxème
édition devrait être organisée l'année
prochaine en attendant les missions
locales et Pôle emploi peuvent également
orienter les jeunes à trouver un contrat
de
professionnalisation donner une nouvelle
dynamique économique à l'lom ération en
prenant mieux en compte les besoins des
entrepreneurs c'est l'objectif de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline l'agglomération
se lance dans une grande enquête auprès
d'eux afin de mieux ressenser leurs
besoins une première rencontre avait
lieu aujourd'hui jeudi 15 septembre en
mairie de morpa l'occasion a d'évoquer
les problèmes auxquels sont confrontés
les dirigeants d'entreprise sur notre
territoire
regardez emploi recrutement et transport
voici quelques-uns des sujets abordés
lors de cette réunion d'un côté des
représentants de 5 an an en Eveline
responsable de l'économie et de
l'insertion professionnelle de l'autre
des entrepreneurs du territoire une
première rencontre pour parler de leurs
besoins et la stratégie à mettre en
place par l'agglomération pour les aider
on voit bien qu'il y a des demandeurs il
y a de l'offre mais comment ça doit
matcher correctement ça a été la grosse
problématique de ce matin voilà et on
voit que ça matche pas bien sur certains
secteurs ce que nous avons
retenu prioritairement c'est sur ces
forums de l'emploi donc c'est quelque
chose que nous avions déjà mis en en
exerg il y a quelques temps mais là
puisque nous sommes rentrés avec les 12
communes évidemment nous allons
réactiver sur les 12 communes donc ça
c'est vraiment un point très positif le
recrutement une des principales
problématiques évoqué ce matin ces
entrepreneurs cherchent à recruter en
priorité sur le territoire pourtant il
rencontre souvent des difficultés pour y
parvenir notre problème je dirais le
plus immédiat c'est d'avoir accès à un
calendrier des prochains forums pour
pouvoir nous en interne nous organiser
et surtout ne pas rater un seul
événement qui nous permettrait la mise
en contact avec de potentiels candidats
en plus de ces échanges une enquête est
menée avec des questionnaires deux
autres rencontres comme celle-ci sont
prévu pour intégrer les entrepreneurs
des 12 communes de l'agglomération
aujourd'hui les entreprises elles
regardent euh vous sa c'est ce qu'on
appelle le B2B B2C B2 maintenant c'est
le B2 territory donc c'estàd que voilà
c'est avec le territoire les entreprises
regardent quelle est la qualité des
services emploi du territoire donc de
l'agglomération prochain rendez-vous le
22 septembre à plaisir et le 29 à
Promopole un séminaire emploi sera par
la suite organisé le 17 octobre afin de
prolonger cette dynamique d'amélioration
du recrutement
local et aujourd'hui débute la semaine
de la mobilité à Saint-Quentin en yvine
au programme animation dans les
entreprises et enquête sur le réseau
skibus mais aussi un jeu la chasse au
bus CIN bus ont été rénovés et Harbor
les nouvelles couleurs de 50 ans en
Yveline le but c'est bien sûr de les
trouver pour cela il faut ouvrir l'œil
et capturer en image l'un de ces cinq
véhic
la photo est à poster sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag Sky la vue un
tirage au sort aura lieu à la fin de
l'opération et le jeu est ouvert
jusqu'au 15 octobre je vous propose
d'écouter à Michel Ogier le président de
cqutin enville nous en dire un peu plus
sur cette semaine de la
mobilité nous souhaitons à travers cette
semaine bien proposer à tous les usagers
un petit
peu les services qui sont apportés tout
au long de l'année par l'agglomération
et puis surtout maître à l'honneur bien
sûr tous ceux qui travaillent on met des
moyens pour que justement il puisse
prendre quelques quelques minutes et
bien comprendre aujourd'hui toutes les
possibilités qui leur sont offertes et
un rendez-vous à noter les ates Euridis
situé à Plaisir organise ses portes
ouvertes demain vendredi 16 et samedi 16
septembre cet établissement de service
et d'aide par le travail favorise
l'insertion des personnes en situation
de handicap les atoridis fait ses 30 ans
cette année accompagnent 64 autes
personnes dans des ateliers
essentiellement artistiques et culturels
comme le théâtre de la couture ou encore
de la menuiserie ces portes ouvertes
seront l'occasion de découvrir le
travail effectué avec leurs élèves
écouter les précisions recueillies par
Patrick JAC de dixmud qu'on fait les 30
ans de ridis on fait aussi
l'inauguration de l'atelier menuserie
que nous avons remixé mis au norme pour
que les travailleurs soient en totale
sécurité au niveau respiratoire et on a
aussi équipé donc nos différents locaux
avec des produits nouveau nouveau et on
souhaite offrir au aux personnes qui
vienent à nous rencontrer un peu une
observation une vue sur toutes nos
compétences et nos valeurs ajoutées je
vous le disais en titre ce weekend ce
sont les journées du patrimoine le thème
cette année concerne le patrimoine et la
citoyenneté il est peut-être temps de
préparer votre programme pour ce weekend
17 milieux seront ouverts partout en
France et saquentin en ivine n'est pas
en reste de la commanderie des Templiers
à hlencour aux hôtels de ville de
guilloncour ou de trappe il y aura de
quoi s'occuper samedi dimanche je vous
propose un petit tour d'horizon préparé
par les soins de Mélanie
poy des salles de spectacles des espaces
de recherche ou encore des mairies les
lieux cinquantinois répondent présents
pour les Journées européennes du
patrimoine à Plaisir la clé des champs
et le théâtre espace Coluche feront
découvrir l'envers du décor j'aurais le
moyen de montrer au public d'éteindre la
salle d'allumer le plateau ce qu'on
appelle en plein feu pour qu'il se rend
compte que quand on a tous ces
projecteurs dans la figure et ben on ne
voit plus le public on ne fait que le
ressentir thème de la citoyenneté oblige
des ouvertures exceptionnelles les
hôtels de ville de trappe aiguille en
cours organise des visites guidées à
hlencour la Commanderie des Templiers
ouvre elle aussi ses portes l'occasion
de pénétrer dans la chapelle rarement
ouverte au public la construction a été
commencée fin du 12e siècle et c'est une
chapelle donc du 13e siècle euh ce qui
est intéressant ici c'est de la revoir
après réouverture donc elle a réouvert
en 2012 après restauration et vous
pourrez découvrir la restauration qui a
été faite à savoir la peinture les
peintures murales voilà et les vitrux
qui ont été nettoyés à de pas de 50 ans
en iveline à saint-rémis les chevreuses
la Fondation marthapanne vous replonge
dans l'atelier et les œuvres de la
sculptrice d'origine hongroise elle a
sculpté ici ses premières œuvres parfois
de très très grandes dimension je je
pense notamment aux sculptures dont
Maurice Béjard s'est emparé pour faire
pour pr de balais euh et puis elle a
effectivement travaillé pendant une
dizaine d'années ici elle travaillait le
bois à ce moment-là à découvrir aussi le
domaine de Madame ellisabeth à
Versailles le Théâtre national de
SaintQuentin en Eveline le Centre
national du cinéma et de l'image animée
à Bois d'Arcy et bien d'autres lieux
encore le patrimoine vous tend les
bras il y aura donc de quoi s'occuper ce
weekend nous reviendrons bien sûr sur
ces journées du patrimoine lundi dans le
journal c'est à présent à la fin de
cette édition je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivi je vous retrouve donc lundi
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
vous souhaite donc une excellente soirée
et un très bon
[Musique]
weekend